[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDACE NAKESHIMANA: In our
work on fairness and AI,
we present a case study on
natural language processing
titled "Identifying
and Mitigating
Unintended Demographic
Bias in Machine Learning."
We will break down what each
part of the title means.
This is the work
that was done jointly
by Chris Sweeney
and Maryam Najafian.
My name is Audace Nakeshimana.
I am a Researcher at MIT, and
I'll be presenting their work.
The content of the slides
presents a high-level overview
of a thesis project that
was done throughout a course
of the year.
It will be released
soon on MIT DSpace.
AI has the power
to impact society
in a vast amount of ways.
For example, in the
banking industry,
many companies are trying to use
machine learning to figure out
if someone will default on a
loan given the data about them.
Now, because machine
learning is used
in the high-stakes
applications, errors
that cause it to be unfair
could cause discrimination,
preventing certain demographic
groups from gaining access
to fair loans.
This problem is
especially important
to address in
developing nations where
there may not be existing
sophisticated credit systems.
Those nations will have to
rely on machine learning models
to make these high-stakes
decisions, such as alternative
credit scoring mechanisms
that are possibly going to be
involving AI more and more.
This work focuses
on applications
of machine learning in
natural language processing.
NLP is important to
studying fairness
in AI because it is used
in many different domains,
from education to marketing.
Furthermore, there
are many sources
of unintended demographic
bias in the standard natural
language processing pipeline.
Here we define the NLP
pipeline as a combination
of steps involved, from
collecting natural language
data to making decisions
based on the NLP models trend
and resulting data.
Lastly, [? therefore, ?] natural
language processing systems
is easier to get.
Unlike tabular systems from
banking or health care,
where companies may be
reluctant to release data
due to privacy
concerns, NLP data,
especially in widely spoken
languages like French
or English, is available from
different sources, including
social media and different
forms of formal and informal
publications, making it more
effective to use in research
on how to make NLP
systems more fair.
We now break down what
unintended demographic bias
means.
The unintended part
means that this bias
comes as an adverse side
effect, not deliberately learned
in a machine learning model.
The demographic part means
that the bias translates
into some sort of inequality
between demographic groups
that could cause discrimination
in a downstream machine
learning model.
And finally, bias is an artifact
of natural language processing
pipeline that causes
this unfairness.
Bias is [INAUDIBLE] term.
Therefore, it is
important that we
center on a specific
form of bias that
causes unfairness in typical
machine learning applications.
In gender-based
demographic bias,
for example, machine
learning model
might associate specific types
of jobs to specific gender
just because it's the way
it is in the data used
to train the model.
Within unintended
demographic bias,
there are two
different types of bias
that will focus on in
natural language processing
applications.
These are bias in
sentiment analysis systems
that analyze positive or
negative feelings associated
with words or phrases
and toxicity analysis
systems designed to detect
derogatory or offensive terms
in words or phrases.
Sentiment bias
refers to an artifact
of the machine learning
pipeline that causes unfairness
in sentiment analysis systems.
And toxicity bias is an
artifact of the pipeline that
causes unfairness in systems
that tries to predict toxicity
from text.
In either sentiment analysis
or toxicity prediction,
it is important that our
machine learning model
doesn't use sensitive
attributes describing
someone's demographic to inform
them whether a sentence should
be positive or negative
sentiment or toxic
or less toxic.
Toxicity classification
is used in a wide variety
of applications.
For example, it can be used
to censor online comments that
are too toxic or offensive.
Unfortunately, these
algorithms can be very unfair.
For example, the decision
of whether sentence
is toxic or non-toxic
can depend solely
on the demographic
identity term,
such as American or Mexican,
that appears in the sentence.
This unfairness can be caused
by many different artifacts
of the natural language
processing pipeline.
For instance, certain
nationalities and ethnic groups
are specifically more
frequently marginalized.
And this is reflected in the
language usually associated
with them.
Therefore, training NLP
algorithms and resulting data
sets could result
in a certain form
of unintended demographic bias.
We want to drive home the point
of unintended demographic bias
versus unfairness.
Unintended demographic bias
can enter a typical machine
learning pipeline from a
wide variety of sources,
from the word corpus
to the word embedding,
the data sent to the algorithm,
and finally from the thresholds
used to make decisions.
The possible unfairness
or the discrimination
comes at the point where
this machine learning
model meets society and
actually causes harm.
This work addresses
mitigating and identifying
unintended demographic
bias at each stage
in the natural language
processing pipeline,
from the words corpus
to the decision level.
Our big goal here
is to find ways
to mitigate the bias
that we might inherently
find in the text corpora
or other types of data
representation that are used
to build NLP applications.
For this module,
we cover measuring
unintended demographic
bias in word embeddings
and using adversarial learning
to mitigate word embedding
bias.
The corresponding
thesis goes further,
and it covers techniques for
identifying and mitigating
unintended demographic bias
at other stages of the NLP
pipeline.
We now cover the work as
measuring word embedding bias.
Word embeddings [? encode ?]
[? text ?] into vector spaces
where distances between words
describe a certain semantic
meaning.
This allows one to
complete the analogy of man
is to woman as king is to queen.
Unfortunately, researchers
Tolga Balukbasi and others
found that even for word
embeddings trained from Google
News articles, there exists bias
in word embedding space, where
the analogy becomes man is to
woman as computer programmer is
to homemaker, another
word for a housewife.
This is concerning given
that word embeddings could
be used in natural language
processing applications devoted
to predicting whether someone
should get a certain job.
However, it is difficult to
quantify the bias just based
on the vector space analogies.
In this work, researchers
Sweeney and Najafian
develop a system to
measure sentiment bias
in word embeddings
to a specific number.
The way they do this is they
take the bias toward embeddings
and use them to
initialize an unbiased
labeled word
sentiments data set.
They train a logistic regression
classifier on this data set,
and they predict
negative sentiment
for a set of identity terms.
For example, in
this case, this is
a set of identity terms
describing demographics
from different national origins.
They analyzed the
negative sentiment
for each identity
term and predict
a score that describes the
bias in word embeddings.
This score is the divergence
between the [INAUDIBLE]
for abilities, for
negative sentiment,
for national origin,
identity terms,
and the uniform distribution.
The uniform distribution
describes a perfectly fair
case, wherein a
demographic is receiving
an equal amount of sentiment
in the word embedding model.
Now that we have a grasp
on the word embedding bias,
we can start to figure out how
to mitigate some of this bias.
In the thesis,
Sweeney and Nafajian
describe how they use
adversarial learning
to debias word embeddings.
Different identity terms can
be more or less correlated
with positive or
negative sentiment.
For example, words like
American, Mexican, and German
can have more correlations with
negative sentiment subspaces
and positive
sentiment subspaces,
because in the
data sets used, it
might appear to be more
frequently associated
with negative or
positive sentiments.
This is concerning.
Even downstream
machine learning model
picks up on these correlations.
Ideally, you want to have
each of those identity terms
to a neutral point between
negative and positive sentiment
subspaces without distorting
their meaning within the vector
space so that the word embedding
model can still be useful.
They use an adversarial learning
algorithm to achieve this.
More details of this
algorithm are described
in the corresponding phases.
I now present some of
their work in evaluating
how adversarial
learning algorithms can
debias word embeddings and make
the resulting natural language
processing system more fair.
We focus on realistic systems
in both sentiment analysis
and toxicity prediction.
For each application,
Sweeney and Najafian
define fairness
metrics to let us
know whether the debiased
word embeddings are actually
helping.
These fairness metrics
often come in the form
of a templates data set.
Researchers have created these
data sets to somewhat tease out
different biases with respect
to different demographic groups.
For example, this set
is meant to tease out
biases between African-American
names and European-American
names when substituting each
name out in the same sentence.
Similar template
data sets have been
created for toxicity
classification algorithms,
where you sub out different
demographic identity
terms within a sentence
and compare differences
in the overall
toxicity predictions.
Sweeney and Najafian
used these templates data
sets to compute fairness for a
real-world toxicity classifier.
This graph shows per-term
AUC distributions
for CNN convolution
neural network
that was trained on a toxicity
classification data set.
The x-axis represents
each demographic group,
where the templates data set
has that identify term subbed
in for each sentence.
Each dot describes a particular
training run of the CNN.
The y-axis describes the
area under the curve accuracy
for this template's data set.
One can see that there
is a lot of disparity
between the accuracies for
different demographic groups.
Ideally, you would want the
variance in different training
runs to be compressed as
well as the differences
between each demographic
group in the AUC scores
to be smaller.
Sweeney and Najafian show
a toxicity classification
algorithm that uses the
debias towards embeddings
creates better results.
This slide shows results for
per-term AUC distributions
for the CNN with different
debias treatments.
Sweeney and Najafian measure how
their word embedding debiasing
compares to other
state-of-the-art techniques.
Further discussion and
evaluation of these graphs
are presented in the
corresponding thesis.
To wrap up, we describe some
key takeaways from this project.
First, there is
no silver bullet.
There are many different
types of applications
and various types of bias
to correct for when trying
to make NLP systems more fair.
Second, bias can emanate
from any stage of the machine
learning pipeline.
Therefore, having to also
identify and mitigate bias
at all stages of the machine
learning pipeline is essential.
Finally, we focus on solving
this problem within an academic
context for natural language
processing pipeline,
but this cannot all
be solved in academia.
For example, much of the
unintended bias in the data
set, like the text corpus,
could come from decisions made
upstream in direct collection.
Furthermore,
unintended bias could
come from decisions
made when deploying
the model into society.
When the model is used
in a way that does not
resonate with how the data was
collected in the first place,
this could cause discrimination.
An example of this is
when the data collected
from a specific
demographic population
is used to make predictions that
affect other demographics that
were not taken into account
during data collection.
Finally, it is important to have
efficient channels of feedback
for these machine
learning models.
The work presented
in this module
highlights why fairness is
a very important concept.
It is therefore critical for
data scientists and engineers
to measure and understand
performance of their models
not just through accuracy,
but also through fairness.
[MUSIC PLAYING]